Người hay mấy tạm của mình một cứ dân cũng chung cơ quan phút có trở biệt, họ đã hương một năm liên tục cạnh báo về tình trạm xuống cấp của hệ thống không trái từ bỏ trở trái, chuẩn bảo động, bình giúp ngoài đến cấp bệ nước có giáo hiệu an mòn.
Bây giờ bản họ của cứ dân với bán khoảng lý cho thấy nhiều hạm mục được liệt vào diện cần sửa chữa hoặc thay mới, nhưng chưa bao giờ được sử lý.
Vìa phụ kiến giản giáo chê, lưới sang và cán lớn mạng chê cũng khiến cư dân lỗi lắng, năm 2019, các quan lâu động tình trình ăn họ dòng và lựa báo chê đáp tình trình trống trái.
Tuy nhiên sau thầm hoạc hiện niết một trọng hai bị tạm với tình mạng và khoảng 2 trong người mất tích.
Cạnh xác lại như các tâm lưới, mạng và mặt trống thấm không đặt tiêu trình, là nặng quên nhân và đáng thú thập thêm trình cử.
Mạng người thu nhà thảo xây dức đã bị bắt, với gạo buộc 1 xác.
Như cư dân nói lúc sốt lắp quan các tự sổ để trống buổi, cũng khiến họ không nhìn thấy khỏi lửa biên ngoài,
chỉ biết sự việc khi nghe người thân gọi.
Một số người dân khác, khoảng 2 trong nhân hút thuốc, ngay cảnh giản giáo,
dù họ tình gửi video cạnh báo, chỉ quyền hôm công tyên bụ sẻ nhiều tra toàn dịnh và tiến hành kìm tra thân tất cả công trình đăng cải tạo.
Nhằm ra sóa phải liệu báo chê và ăn toàn giản giáo, rất là sống hoàn y vì sao hàng loch cạnh báo cũng như rất bị bọn ngọt, sức 1 năm trời.